was glaube jetzt willkommen bei neuen
video und das war wahrscheinlich das
allerletzte mal dass ihr dieses intro
gesehen haben nein leute keine angst ich
werde nicht auf mit youtube ist das
geilste was es gibt somit zu auf der
welt so für mich zurzeit allerdings gibt
es also eine sache die habe ich mich
irgendwie noch nie so getraut
anzusprechen beziehungsweise ich habe in
letzter zeit immer mehr gemerkt dass es
mir richtig auf den sack geht und zwar
handelt es sich da wenn sie häufig oder
um keine ahnung was sondern ganz stumpf
gesagt einfach um meinen namen den ich
auf youtube dieser name ist eigentlich
schon mega alt ich glaub vier jahre wenn
nicht sogar älter also ich hatte früher
mal ein dschungel der hieß ein
blockbuster weil ich da blogs gemacht
habe und diesen namen habe ich dann halt
auf diesen job übernommen
allerdings passt der name wenn man
überlegt komplett überhaupt nicht mehr
ich mein wann habe ich hier meinen blog
hochgeladen vielleicht vor einem jahr
mal irgendeinen oder so und blockbuster
passt halt nicht versteht ihr ich mach
einfach videos wo ich mich hinstelle was
euch erzählen wo ich irgendeinen kaka
mache oder so aber dieser name passt
nicht und er geht mir auch wirklich zur
zeit mega auf den bisher gefällt mir
einfach nicht mehr und hört sich meiner
meinung nach auch ein bisschen kindisch
an soja los jetzt auf den punkt zu
bringen ich habe wirklich ganz sagen den
und her überlegt mir auch mega viele
leute so habe mich so ein bisschen
beraten ja was ich machen soll wie ich
mich denn jetzt denn soll ob ich nicht
überhaupt nennen soll
und ich habe jetzt ein entschluss
gefasst und zwar hab ich es
wahrscheinlich auch schon die unten
gelesen ich heiße nicht mehr blockbuster
sondern so komisch irgendwie alex v was
soll das denn heißen okay also passt auf
ich hatte irgendwann auch schon mal so
ein bisschen angekündigt dass sie in
zukunft vielleicht noch das eine oder
andere ändern werde ich noch mal da und
da mich ein bisschen ausprobieren werde
das werde ich auch machen es kommt mega
viel auf euch zu ich habe ja viel
geplant
und da macht der name work pasta wird
überhaupt gar keinen sinn mehr
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht ja kommen
so alex da kann man einiges ein brandl
rausmachen absolut überlegen irgend
etwas cooles mir ist irgendwie nichts
eingefallen
und dann habe ich mir gedacht kommen
blockbuster das hatte ich so weit
gebracht jetzt schon irgendwas musste
davon aber drin lassen und dieser name
spielt mir schon so seit circa drei
wochen im kopf herum und ich wusste
nicht ob ich das jetzt wirklich
durchziehen soll
habe ich einfach gemacht scheiß drauf
ich mach's besser jetzt als in irgendwie
dem jahr wohl eher noch mehr leute hier
zu gucken und sich dann noch mehr weiter
umstellen müssen aber einiges ja auch
gar keine umstellung ich mal nur der
name ist anders ich hoffe ihr kommt
damit alle klar ist nur der name ich
bleib so alex wie ich alt bin ich hoffe
ihr versteht meine entscheidungen könnt
ihr mal schreiben was ihr darin jetzt
gut findet und was ihr schlecht findet
oder wenn euch der name gefällt könnt
ihr mir meinetwegen ja das ist jetzt
wieder ein bisschen der leica so also
wenn euch der name gefällt dann könnt
ihr ein danke oben geben oder einen
kommentar schreiben
wenn euch nicht gefällt könnt ihr auch
gerne daumen nach unten geben dann sehe
ich dass direkt und ja aber ich denke
dass gewöhnungssache jeden man hat ja
jeder dran gewöhnen und dann 30 halt
jetzt einfach so absolut zur aussprache
noch das soll jetzt nicht alex v
ausgesprochen werden also wenn ihr zu
eurem tun gesagt erkennst du den seine
videos in voller der heißt alex v ich
heiße jetzt nicht alex v sondern
bisschen englisch ausgesprochen so cool
alex wie ok hört sich vielleicht erst
mal scheiße an aber ich jetzt das beste
meiner meinung nach ich bin damit
zufrieden vor drei wochen darauf mich
auch noch scheiß angehört jetzt finde
ich in mega cool so an sich mit dem
namen kann man wirklich in alle
richtungen was machen und er wird immer
passen deswegen ist es jetzt an der name
ich hoffe ihr kommt damit alle klar wie
gesagt stellt eure meinung in die
kommentare interessiert mich wirklich
sehr
und ansonsten ist natürlich das normal
am nächsten sonntag wieder da kommen
wieder ein ganz normales video wie auch
sonst nur der name ist halt anders und
es gibt ein neues intro das bestimmt
auch léa pool wird ab sofort in sallam
hat sich auch schon alex wie auf
facebook auch es ist mir scheißegal nach
2 von der werkstatt bleibt natürlich so
bestehen an sonst würde ich sagen hatte
wir sehen uns halt sonntag wieder ab